one of the things you can be virtually
certain of in life is that you don't get
something you don't aim at and one of
the things that's interesting about that
is often people will keep their goals
fuzzy because one of the problems with
specifying your goals is you specify
your failures right if the goal is
really fuzzy you're not sure when you
fail and that then you can fool yourself
you know really but you can kind of keep
it foggy but you make your goal sharp
and clear then well first of all then
you know what to aim at and what's
interesting is you know your brain is
set up so that it reorganizes the world
around your aims and that's not I've
also written about this in 12 rules for
life quite extensively and that's not a
metaphor like we don't see much of the
world because there's a lot of the world
and there isn't much of us and so we see
what we aim at we aim with our eyes and
here's an example so a great apes don't
really have much of a white in their
eyes but human beings do and the reason
for that is that we've evolved to detect
where everyone else is looking and so if
I can't tell where you're looking I
don't know what you're up to and then
well over time that means I can't read
you as well and more we're more likely
to get in a dispute and one or the other
of us is more likely to get killed but
it also means that your your probability
of findings as successful mate decreases
so we've evolved to have this very very
visually evident eye and so when we're
looking at each other we're always
looking at our our eyes because then we
can tell where someone is pointed and
then we can tell what they're up to
and so we're hunting creatures like
we're aiming at a moving target and
trying to track it all the time and so
you have to specify your aim and the
future authoring program helps people
specify the Raymond it's more than one
aim it's like you have a highest aim
which you might say is to be a good
person and then I would say well there's
a there's a more elaborated aim than
that it's like you want to be able to
constrain malevolence and work to
decrease suffering it's something like
that that's the highest aim and and then
and then you have to decompose that into
the things you do each day so that
there's a definite connection between
all the micro actions and the macro
and then that gives dignity to what
you're doing